live this is 8 news now weekend there is
not sufficient evidence for us to
conclude that social media is in fact
sufficiently safe for our kids social
media it's entertaining and some teens
can't get enough but America's top
doctor is sounding the alarm have you
noticed your teen on their phone a lot
more well you may want to take notice
the U.S Surgeon General is issuing the
first ever Public Health advisory on the
negative negative effects that social
media can have on your team's mental
health 8 news now reporter Victoria Saha
spoke to a local performance coach on
the effects
adults many of us often find ourselves
mindlessly scrolling through social
media from Facebook to Instagram to tick
tock it becomes quite addicting in the
therapeutic and Counseling World we've
been seeing these effects for a very
very long time the facts Lindsay Powell
lead the Mind performance coach says
could stay with teens for a long time
you're seeing everybody's best version
rather than their average day-to-day
lifestyle and it's easy to Envy someone
who posts about their new vacation or
new purchases but the comparison isn't
healthy for teens the U.S Surgeon
General Vivek Murthy recently came out
with an advisory regarding social media
and youth mental health in it he says
social comparison driven by social media
is associated with body dissatisfaction
disordered eating and depressive
symptoms for teens they're still
developing and really creating the true
perception of what life looks like right
and so when we're messing with that
perception in a time where they're
vulnerable and still growing and still
understanding the world we're setting
them up for
um
I would say damaging their development
Paul Lisa's parents should also put down
ground rules regarding phone use and do
as you say so it's easier for your teen
to follow your lead Victoria Saha 8 news
now it's suggested to limit social media
use for about two hours a day for your
team encourage more in-person group
activities so they aren't just
connecting with their friends on screens